vivienda y el empleo es decir que los
vemos un quinquenio muy particular
controles fronterizos aquí tengo su
esto es algo sorprendente en su programa
pagar las facturas al fin del mes y
aquéllos y que hacen parte de las
envío sus saldos incluso los detenidos
estoy perfectamente de acuerdo
yo no espero las crisis como porque a mí
también quiero reformar el liceo
respetar la ley haciendo que regresen a
no son los barrios más pobres de la
primero es poner un primer ministro que
ahí es donde estamos entonces los medios
tengo que interrumpirla para recordarle
realidad ha debido ser lanzado hace años
pienso que hay que volver a las certezas
que yo les presento a los franceses a
víctimas como el
ruralidad gracias a los medios que
la industria y el esfuerzo que hay que
democracia no fueron escuchados ni en
que hoy hay que intensificar y mantener
jubilación de los 65 años es algo
empleo parcial así es como se protege la
religión es el islam y saadi si quieren
importantes y mientras más se trabaja
caso hoy porque el 20 por ciento de los
mantengo en memoria lo que ocurrió hace
dos o tres días le aseguró que cuando
están reunidos todos los habitantes
de médicos y
unos que superaban más de mil millones
decirlo porque hay millones de personas
difícil donde no nos ayudan en la casa
puesto en funcionamiento en ese momento
trabajan son valientes después de todo
gobierno nos ayudó el consejo de estado
que lo que usted está proponiendo no es
habla mucho es el sufrimiento animal
que se ha grabado una verdadera crisis
de desierto médico con un método
que hay algo de confusión es de suprimir
hay que rearmar a los policías primero
usted quiere ser diferencia el primer
francesa ha sufrido tanto ha sufrido
quisiera decirles que se puede elegir
usted tres minutos para responder si ese
esta política es correcta pero hay que
últimos años dos años y medio
qué es lo que yo no deseo tendrán que
hidroelectricidad eso nos sirve para
quieren un cambio de práctica y eso es
a las naciones soberanas y respeten sus
de hacer de lograr que esta guerra no
nuestro debate hace cinco años en parte
necesitamos formarlos y por eso en
programación militar y hacer que francia
ofreces en cliente usted lo piensan en
como la de francia y por eso invertí en
grandes y no para los pequeños cuando
muestran que el nivel de conocimientos
que se ve muchos señores no somos
psicológicos a veces graves porque para
salir de un tema que ha sido apasionante
sufrimiento de tanto de los enfermeros
con segundo en torno al localismo a la
dinero a los franceses
retoma cada fin de semana entonces
entonces avanzamos pero combatiendo
de hablar del modelo económico de las
resto del mundo para poder comprender
creó una política espacial
totalmente escandalizada la manera como
la autonomía y espero que podamos hablar
de elecciones y de referendo pero
después de él preside- pero
las familias monoparentales
reformar el mercado de la electricidad
ley que prohíba el velo
catastróficos pero se podría porque
quiere responder a lo que acaba de decir
hay que apoyarse en una visión pero
formando a los niños y adolescentes y
nuevos cupos en las prisiones porque es
y también quiero decirle señor marco que
euros y esto está condicionado a nada ya
otros países porque muchos se ven
los depredadores de arriba y a los
fue una medida de buena medida y lo
contra del bloqueo de los precios porque
revistas y también usted no está de
locales y la seguridad social porque
como horizonte pero también desarrollar
de hablar de conservación con los
problema en algunos de sus eventos
respecto a ellos fue realmente violento
las categorías veces usted dice que bajó
sospechas de justamente de separatismo y
apoyó esta medida y usted también no
islámico
se roban el combustible de los carros se
agresores
acusadas de ser impuras
perdió a su hijo que cayó en un acto
para que las empresas se embolsen pero
no hay una sola palabra en su programa
internacional no reconoce rara vez o no
aislarlas para poder actuar de manera
cultural que es un proyecto para la
programa y usted me habla de pensar que
república donde lo hicimos y la invito a
absoluta de los cinco primeros años es
centenas de miles de trabajadores
islamistas pienso que la gran mayoría de
hablar sobre sus propuestas en este
de este gran debate de la campaña de
si tuviéramos precios regulados como los
verdaderamente mala estoy tratando de no
hacer
de retraso
desafortunadamente no duró mucho tiempo
expresé las alertas que lancé porque
están ahí lo que significa que haya
constitucional lo que a mis ojos es un
discutir con alguien porque incluso con
de confianza con respecto a los selectos
el señor putin entonces no no también la
todos los meses es bueno este es el fin
la energía solar
las mujeres jóvenes que lo usan no
en este esto los criterios de dificultad
gana el dinero a costa de los residentes
de nuevo es la deuda de kobe que ayudó a
que nos están escuchando en millones de
cerramos esas asociaciones y
alemanes sacrificando a los ganaderos o
curso se puede avanzar porque alguien
escuela quiero un grandes objetivos a
cinco años cuando debatimos en otro
tiene ningún sentido esto crea desempleo
tomado muy mal la respuesta que usted
mismos decía es que está un poquito el
cpd que es el acrónimo que es para
perenne su dinero pero estudio minuto
vivir tranquilamente y quieren poder que
inflacionistas inflacionarios porque por
le quitaron el velo a las mujeres
lo que más me golpeó conforme hablamos
respecto al clima por eso es que las
de la pena es mejor poner una pena
de euros y hoy son más de 25 y van a
francia necesitamos una política de
y es por eso que quiero poner ahí un
tener poder adquisitivos fue luchar
respetar una constitución entonces
franceses no se dan exclusivamente sino
yo pienso nuestros policías todos los
hizo unas propuestas que yo quiero poder
sea una fuerza de equilibrio que permita
prácticamente la mitad se hizo bajo
las matemáticas después las volvió a
8000 puestos administrativos de
podemos hablar de escuelas de la
sobre áfrica
hacia dónde quieren ir ayudar en la
grandes dificultades de nuestra
cuanto a la proporcional porque usted no
que nos quedan tres años para limitar a
comida por día estos ni estos niños y
rearmarnos moralmente hay que hacer hay
es cierto y está actual
no se están tomando decisiones
sus países no solamente los clandestinos
también hablamos de
y ya podremos comenzar el hidrógeno no
nosotros pusimos y a las reformas que
pescadores el yo hablé con ellos pero yo
profesional porque hay un tercio de los
para ellos para ellas es decir duplicar
en poner una medida suplementaria y
es del todo nuclear no es posible y
estudiar y trabajar al tiempo no es
como de los pacientes porque todo el
estructuras decían que no había ninguna
relocalización de la producción y de las
como la gente ya no podía trabajar no
importantes y lo que va a guiar mis
que nos miran expresar mi solidaridad y
últimos cinco años esta es una prioridad
usted propone son al mismo tiempo
cuando veo los resultados evitamos
inversión en energías renovables darse
en la energía solar en las zonas rurales
principio si medios franceses confían en
la justicia de 30 por ciento en los
hacer es con la industria
quiero es presentarle a los franceses un
completamente nuevo a escala del
resultados porque la delincuencia en los
si eso está en la constitución el único
jóvenes que sufrieron durante el cob y
visión de lo que debe ser la unión
se llama la sharia pienso que este
minutos de avance más bien 4 de retraso
en el mar que vamos a desarrollar hay
tenemos que invertir con todas las
para que no dependa más de las pequeñas
decisiones incluso sus decisiones de
de la prioridad nacional cuando hablemos
quiero restituirles a los franceses los
se prestan más problemas en términos de
que hemos debido tener una reflexión
evidente que muchos magistrados no
establecer una verdad y esta pandemia no
pero también puede hablar de los otros
franceses pero también les devolveré
nuestra armada para tener para hacer los
es exactamente el sentido de la ley que
gran dificultad es que las filiales de
y la prima de poder adquisitivo que será
usted ha defendido la energía eólica que
otra vía basada en el respeto y en el
disciplinados
avances en el tema de los trabajadores
ellos fue muy difícil atravesar la
los estudios y también revisar los
falso
y cada uno podrá verificarlo entonces a
usted
defienden ideas como estudios no tomaron
yo hice más viajes que ninguno de mis
tanto los jóvenes durante los dos
país en el mundo que prohibiría el verbo
nuestra constitución nuestros textos
depredadores de abajo es decir a los
estamos en los mismos términos para cada
los impuestos sobre el captura sobre los
yo creo que hay que dejar esto en el
bueno yo dije que iba a empezar el
yo pienso que hay una diferencia yo
escaleras etcétera después hay que poder
10% blanco lo contrario pero lo que yo
que habla de preferencia nacional contra
de los más viejos entre nosotros tenemos
hizo sobre la indemnización del
contra el islamismo radical el que
escuela para mí decisivo y
pueden hacerlo de otra manera aunque no
europa y eso va a cambiar por supuesto
hemos hecho haciendo como yo he tratado
los compatriotas que nos escuchan y en
para los medios en los últimos años pero
brasileros quiero informarle que en
productividad es de 0 1% en cambio él
riesgos van a ser los ciber ataques
todos fueron puestos bajo vigilancia
pero yo lo asumo pero en la vida
que
poner en obra poder reducir estos
formato antes de la primera vuelta
fuimos el primer país en el mundo a
manuel marco ambos usaron la palabra
crisis profunda por la pandemia
problema lo segundo es que tenemos que
acuerdo
vidas también la vida de nuestros
utilizarán cada vez más estos medios y
esto sí creo realmente una fuerte
de los alumnos franceses está bajando
estamos frente a una barbarie que se
quito y lima nos conectamos en directo
prohíben en la escuela usted no va a
radicalizados que molestan a la
sentido y luego distinguir
segundos
está hablando a su banquero cuando habla
personas no creen en su voluntad de
esta situación no es admisible en
ahora no se han hecho intentos y
sino obviamente los delincuentes y los
fuerte
magistrados también para
también para él las pensiones promedio
hecho esta medida y hago que este
más preguntas para usted señor más con
la laicidad es un tema importante es un
formación de excelencia académica de
privados de vínculos sociales privados a
80% de ellos las cifras detrás de este
eficaz que mis medidas sobre el iva pero
europea de esta pregunta leemos después
república pero la en antiguo oficio se
de todos combatimos con nuestras
fácil y
utilizar adjetivos demasiado
acaba de decir es completamente lo
y
territorio es decir vas al trabajar al
dramas como ocurrieron en eeuu con otros
mi plan
sobre la ecología sí sí hay un pequeño
decirle que el pueblo es soberano y que
orientación porque es uno de los dramas
que miren las zonas rurales que tanto me
posiciones que defienden sus
tiempo que tenemos que es casi un
nivel nacional
partes el problema señor blanco es que
detrás de esto los valores de europa y
creas emisiones de gases de efecto
días y eso no significa abandonarlos
muy respetuoso yo creo que se ve mucho
pequeña de 458 días y no que seguramente
incluso las instituciones ustedes dos
del fmi para tomar las cifras
discutido con china con india con los
últimos cinco años fueron a solicitar
últimos años
más tiempo en el eólico terrestre por
lo hizo no sé si realmente preocupado
propongo llevar el mínimo que es de 980
referendo sobre la inmigración este
si no hubiésemos reabierto las escuelas
lo había prometido en 2017 lo cumplió
quiso aplicar en un cartel y por qué
desplazados llegan a nuestro país a
más 400.000 pobres más después de su
y creo que no ha sido hecho sirve estoy
brutal
desempleo que tan sólo afectó a los más
prioritariamente
todo la presidenta de la concordia
habíamos tenido algo así en un siglo
en este mandato en términos de salud y
de la república claro a mí me educaron
que al mismo tiempo es muy injusto y
un nivel aceptable las emisiones de gas
no yo no lo digo yo quito los cargos del
lo vemos desde la segunda guerra mundial
muchas de ellas
fundamentales dicen eso es el laicismo
actividades quiero que se pueda crear en
yo propongo y gracias por permitirme
para contestar si hay algo sorprendente
islamismo debe ser combatido con una
el islamismo radical sí
déficit económico y en términos de
pueden decretar una pena cuando saben
crear una planificación energética de
impuesto sobre las fortunas el sentido
compasión absoluta con el pueblo
si somos maestros de escuela les diremos
acuerdos de parís y luchamos contra la
tengo una gratitud infinita con estos
en los consejos de disciplina ya no se
las mismas elecciones y encontraron
mil puestos de policía se crearon porque
un organismo de empleo al que usted hace
pero la pregunta
mí lo que significa que es una
fuerte de peso con una defensa fuerte
quiero hacer en los departamentos que es
que concertar con los pescadores con
manera habría que hacer un google
simple porque en esa época después del
bienes particularmente ha disminuido
la misma pregunta frente a esta crisis
que mejorar también el nivel de las
renovar la vida democrática o se tiene
entonces hay evidencias de que estamos
ya la mitad de ellos están inactivos
que están en liceo y quiero poder
se atrevan a decirlo porque a las que no
usted también dio unas cifras para darle
larga hay que mantenerlo y se tiene
esto y yo esté convencido de que nuestra
lo describió es un dispositivo de crisis
islámico entre espacios públicos
fronteras entonces tenemos que reforzar
que son parte de un todo lo que yo
medio ambiente un tema muy esperado por
crisis sanitaria por eso es muy evidente
meses es una realidad y comparto
predecesores al
fines de meses difíciles para las
insoportable señor mccomb pensar que los
gracias gracias gracias a todos por
mejorada de mis palabras eso está allí y
energética y en el futuro habrá
maltrato para eso hay que dar una
establecer si de libertad de fragancia
delincuentes y criminales que acosan a
creo y lo repito que estamos obligados
repubblica estos deberían ser expulsados
dispositivo que permitirá y tener
era para ayudar a estas personas a poder
producción es la posición francesa eso
usted no puede reemplazar
su mano simplemente a su mano muchas de
todos sus amigos cuando yo veo cómo
europa que es lo que acaba de hacer
inmigración clandestina utilizan el
ahí también las cosas entre ellas el
segundos señor mejor ella no respondió
república laica el laicismo no es
que tienen la juventud del día de hoy
justicia de actuar
noemi y magistrados que usted propuso y
creamos y la ley de trabajo en él desde
la vida europa hay que ir más lejos creo
es importante me parece muy injusto se
roban los cultivos agrícolas las
soberano es el pueblo no el concepto de
pero después vamos a llevar esto de
usted quiere quitarle su velo está
diferencias por nuestros niños y una de
particularmente escucho los reproches de
es una fuente de energía no pero se lo
sobre cómo establecer el medio para
modelo que también causa mucho mal a los
división hay que volver a coser a que
esto es un verdadero proyecto para los
supuesto los comerciantes dicen ok como
las personas en un país que no es el
es de cualquier manera creo que hay que
pero
poner los medios para sí segundo que son
pero por ahora la misma pregunta para
al debate presidencial de francia entre
inversión de inversión en la
contaminante o se necesita energía
pero yo no veo hacer las cosas y usted
para ella como para mí es evidente que
el laicismo es un principio de libertad
uno con la misma pregunta tiene usted de
mecanismo sea obligatorio pero usted no
verdadera
unos de categoría a abc etcétera son
quiero decirle a quienes nos escuchan
tiempos porque cuando toman 18 meses
nuestro país por eso hay que liberar a
refrendo sobre la inmigración tiene por
criminales y también
cambiar su discurso era mucho más yo
dependencia y este es un tema que ha
tenemos 15 minutos de retraso con
reunido todos dicen es que no nos queda
eso divide el 2 para llevarlo a 2050
estos servicios hacen un trabajo
personal en el hospital con nuestra
escéptica con respecto al clima nunca
intercambios y cada uno es responsable
contrariamente a lo que usted dice no se
años notó que el 80 por ciento era
seguridad social y las colectividades
librito sí entonces voy a volver sobre
veces de su familia privados de sus
ucraniano
ultramar por ejemplo podemos hablar muy
aliviarles la carga porque uno de los
que hayan tenido un primer empleo
exhortamos porque son estadounidenses o
sistema privado porque en la medicina
rusia y ese es el problema señor el epen
república que es orgullosa de sí mismo y
invernadero
porque en realidad la que tiene la
países del golfo para que puedan tomar
países europeos que a veces formaron 30
contra los servicios públicos y
una conferencia social en otoño conducir
que basarse en la presunción de legítima
quieren ser actores de los cambios que
falso estoy simplemente obtuvo que de
razón
deforestación en la segundo y
hablado tampoco de la seguridad en las
préstamos en los bancos franceses para
regularización de aproximadamente el 10%
claro quizás usted se sorprenda pero en
usted sabía que ese banco de la
separa de la república sin confundir el
aquellos que utilizan esas zonas para
volvió salvaje estamos viviendo para
contrario
mejor si estarán mucho mejor
conjuga lización para quienes conocen
precios de la energía que son la
resolver todos estos problemas y voy a
financiamiento en bancos franceses
muy creo en lo que quiero crear el marco
democrática
ya sea con respecto a proteger a los
es directamente el pueblo el que puede
tomado en cuenta por el estado es darles
seguro que todo va en contra de ellos
asilo y en muchos países europeos nos
el único límite que yo expresé también
lo usan dicen que son las que terminan
que no será aplicada y esto es algo que
quiero es luchar contra el islamismo
importante fue la supresión del impuesto
caso no es la unión europea' usted
beligerancia en materia de entrega de
de efecto invernadero señora lópez si
pueblo hay soberanía francesa pero no
primer confinamiento ya se sabía que en
trimestrales son de 54 porque es
europea la pregunta es simple y va para
una parte y una planificación
decisiones usted implantó el impuesto
suyo entonces esta política hay que
del segundo trimestre la inflación es de
sociedad lo que hacemos cuando votamos
porque lo que acabamos de vivir es una
puede defender los intereses de francia
en los últimos días pronunciaron en
50% y además crea sufrimiento animal y
se bloquea los precios pero también
justamente eso es más la fe en sí por
balance son es la dependencia a los
común de su terminal con una
referencia a tal vez no le gusta pero
investigación donde como quiero hacerlo
son situaciones de fragilidad porque
aumento tiene que ver con las violencias
fuertemente y las cifras también están
constitución señor depende del único
no perdón ya ver ya volveremos a hablar
escuelas de momento se hizo con
bajen no voy a aumentar la deuda quiero
es la deuda que usted votó en contra
yo no puedo durante este quinquenio va a
llevada a seis mil euros sin impuestos
de lo contrario de las posiciones que ha
reintegrará y les restituirá los
servicios
personas entonces lo que nosotros
conflicto porque no somos vasallos de
hospitales y los terroristas los
combatir a una religión
nos vemos obligados a pasar al tema
restaurada entre los franceses se ve la
de la base instalada que es sobre todo
se lo informó y hay que poder producir
atreven a tomar decisiones y aplicar
me comprometo porque he construido los
manuel majo y maggie leppel nos
hidrógeno verde también
mandato primero los son los feminicidios
agricultores si está razonado y también
desmantelamiento pero ya hay 2000 que
quinquenio 400.000 pobres en un país en
punto importante de los programas de
darles el 20 por ciento de su salario a
euros a 1.100 euros estos progresos hay
y yo sé que usted se opuso a esta medida
europa
usted estar proponiendo una prohibición
miedo a la gente sobre 10 mil 600
para mí que la juventud sea la prioridad
sociales y además que los empresarios
franceses
cerró 14 reactores nucleares pero al
podemos avanzar bueno marín depende
pero con esta medida usted las hace
problemas de poder adquisitivo para los
y
nuclear o energía renovable si usted
se cumpla y no una pena de un año que no
también es un sistema privado pero hay
entonces en la escuela no hay velo
usted no tiene respuesta es es normal
y si yo quiero ser una gran potencia
contratar y poder retomar actividades
locales señores de pena ya hay que
manejar una crisis del cob y me siento
última palabra sobre este tema de la
pagarles quiero inspirarme del éxito de
medicina con los paramédicos
porque es algo fundamental y la
poco entonces hay una lista que yo
sus palabras no todos fueron adoptados
haber respetado el espíritu y las reglas
asilo protegido por nuestra constitución
hablado son grandes pero hoy puede haber
sobre el cob y yo expliqué lo que eran
el terreno y consumir
animales porque cuando se aceptan
protegió como ciudadanos y tiene que ir
justifica desde el punto de vista de
digo no es una fuente de energía para
territorial de otra parte para la
que están por fuera del tema pero
fuerza como al mismo tipo que vladimir
afectado a todos los franceses después
vamos a comenzar por el primer tema de
tratando de ponerme en los zapatos de
usted se el fraude es decir que el que
que usted no hay son diferentes pues voy
increíble y debo decir con
democracia llenaría un déficit
significativa antes de la edad de 20
el cheque de 100 euros que usted le
sus elecciones están ahí se explican por
industrias los animales incluso los
se requiere firmeza
lo que yo digo de francia es que es una
las energías renovables que quiere
un servicio completo y permitir que
defensa ellos han sufrido con el
sobre las grandes fortunas
manera local para darle los medios para
conservar los datos en el territorio
cambiar las 2.800 es directamente el
respecto a lo que teníamos previsto para
estadísticas bien conocidas de todas
europeo se acaba y que las mercancías
tiempo de atender a todos los pacientes
porque no se puede hacer desde seguridad
tengo un discurso muy fuerte con leyes
nadie cuenta las categorías b y c porque
avanzar en sus proyectos pero hay que
de todas maneras vamos a recibir el
las clases
porque contrariamente a las que usted ha
las cosas que me importan más si los
modelo que molesta a los franceses y con
proponiendo eso es lo que está
aplicable solamente si
es lo que nos permitió mantener el
como de oliva
objeto cambiar las reglas sobre la
los valientes él vence el sentido común
sensibles a la evolución que estamos
ahí que son el fruto de la implicación
puntos cuando las situaciones del
remendar la democracia francesa y yo
siempre confunde la unión europea y
intrafamiliar es eso no le quita
hubiera podido bajar los impuestos que
tomado en el pasado una de las primeras
millones para la revalorización salarial
comprar carros o casas y no obtuvieron
decirle porque ellos tienen razón que es
pandemia que no habíamos vivido en un
consultas y ese es el caso desde el 2019
de penn eso es importante porque esta
calentamiento es interesante al
tomen la jubilación cuando ya no son
cambiar señora me concediera mi
cotizaciones porque es el coste que
en 10 años y en europa tenemos que tener
esperar como el año pasado a llegar
esto porque dice claramente lo que llevó
entonces conmigo no habrá prohibición ni
lugares de culto ahí 1099 que tenían
mirando con lucidez y coraje en nuestra
hidrocarburos y usted propuso la mayor
los tocan no quieren que venga de una
soberano es el pueblo como la
ustedes sobre todo el sueño más señora
globalización que
democrática
correctamente porque sus intereses
los franceses y yo considero que la
los franceses entonces todos sus amigos
legal para poder hacer esto de patrullas
el ministerio del interior que está
explíqueme porque no es verdad la
que tener uno que esté controlado
si en las cifras aumentan a más del 80
palabras como referéndum
visión todo se acabaron para termina en
pusieron bajo presión fuertemente y yo
salarios de los cuales se vieron
y 35 semanas nosotros no lo hicimos
cuando hay posiciones difíciles por
presupuesto señor marco la misma
reapertura de las carrileras eso pero
más a ucrania y entregarle armas hay que
promedio 150 a 200 euros por mes y por
realidad los pequeños comercios no eran
rusia que debe hacer francia hasta dónde
chinos y por que steve jobs heras donde
no fue el origen ni de allá ni de alves
social son diez mil millones para la
proporcional es la asamblea nacional se
sobre el carbono lo que agravó el precio
siempre recaen sobre quienes no tienen
se cumple los países bajos me dan la
todos los países musulmanes en donde los
para los asalariados es una prima que
de este debate democrático y gracias a
en
reconocimiento 23 fueron cerradas 36
quiero avanzar en este sentido sobre las
para un asilo es difícil es darles un
más allá aún no estamos ahí pero tenemos
es muy nocivo por eso pienso que hay que
volvamos al tema del colegio
todas estas mujeres hay que hacer que
seguridad en las escuelas y el respeto a
colegio abierta porque yo no me olvido
visitar yo sobre este principio pues sí
combatiendo su religión
orgulloso de la manera como nosotros lo
desarrollarlos el único manera de poder
el conocimiento de las matemáticas era
presidenta de la justicia seré la
me sorprende algo y es que durante su
hacer lo mismo que hicimos
no permite no permitirá llegar ahí
medios no no pero qué medios va a usted
expresen temor de expresión temor que es
dicho no he olvidado mis manos sus la
siguientes sus palabras son fascinantes
van a llegar
de una ley de rechazo porque está
en france los las cargas que pagan no
podría hacer pero creo que en el fondo
aprobar lo que se llama el mínimo
con palabras y con posturas se hace con
siendo aisladas insultadas marginadas y
esenciales y ahí permitiendo que mejoren
a notar que muchos de mis predecesores
esta dependencia pero y simplemente le
de la publicación de un libro en las
siglo gracias a la impresión de la
islam y el islamismo ríndete entiende
crecimiento de 0.6 por ciento y
democrático de los bancos que parecían
trimestre a trimestre entonces acabo de
maneras hay personas que están buscando
que lo logren llegaremos al final de la
con los farmacias en los enfermeros de
la nuclear y es lo que nosotros nos
cotidiano que es insoportable para los
podrán darle a los franceses una
favor si todo está perfecto los felicito
hicimos con esta creación de puestos
porque estamos formando conciencias no
medidas coyunturales como la supresión
confundir todo señor de premios posibles
comunidad usted pronunció el tema del
franceses confían en mí es continuar
queríamos preguntar el exceso del
escucharla es la incoherencia de la
donde habían 9 millones 800 mil pobres
tiene el renovable vamos a producir
viviendo hoy de los precios de la
años entre los 17 y los 20 años todos
gastar los 30 años y también una ayuda
proponiendo de manera concreta y
personales están ligados a las personas
hasta enero porque ahora tenemos una
donde voy a donde quiera que yo vaya
que es funesta para ella misma y para el
esto realmente le causa mucho mal a
a cabo hace un momento cuando yo fui
europeo
potencia mundial y no solamente una
son activos parciales no pero nos
doctor y ver ayudo a las soluciones
razón hacer dinero con la vulnerabilidad
europa europa es europa
quiero ir más allá el salario mínimo
este quinquenio en términos de el
salíamos del euro no hemos comprendido
que serán dineros públicos y lo digo y
clausurar este debate les quedan dos
inmigración que están en curso de su es
producción de energías pero también para
sanciones
pero allí no es el estado en que paga el
que poder financiarlos y antes de estos
de un mandato si los franceses confían
entonces yo quiero esas escuelas
de la culpa ni de él el velo islámico
en el marco de arquitectura de seguridad
privados
el trabajo no hay cientos de miles de
pudimos ver una cosa es que tenemos
cultivos
constitución es la ley suprema sólo el
final de su mandato usted dice me
donde enseñan los docentes los niveles
unión europea tal y como está hoy con la
imagen desde la pregunta para ambos la
por supuesto hay que prevenir pero
que usted quiere reemplazar la soberanía
hicimos bueno podemos pasar el tema del
próximo domingo yo seré la presidenta de
estoy a favor del renacimiento
es una es malo para la biodiversidad es
clandestinos que están en este fichero
tienen apenas pocos segundos de
cultas no han iniciado de francia la
quiero mantener ahora es ante los presos
atravesé
pueblo el que puede cambiar la
cláusula que cuando nosotros le pregunté
la precariedad y presentaron problemas
es de inversión por un lado más de 19
fuertes tenemos resultados los alcaldes
pregunta que la señora lepén si lo
importancia las demás todas estas vidas
del brasil estoy en desacuerdo con la
coste usted votó en contra señor repente
desprecio de su gobierno de ser
ser la revisión constitucional que
chalecos amarillos usted suspendió esta
que hicimos en los últimos 5 años es
revalorización del personal y también
circular de parís quieren más tener más
ocuparse de estas personas de la tercera
medios los que tienen lados no tienen
que se ven perseguidas incluso a veces
subvención para los hidrocarburos porque
islamistas engañados le han ganado le
este en este estado general de la
hubiera podido perfectamente hacerla
para justamente responder y proteger de
problema de nuestra economía pienso yo
de proteger
viudas a quienes se les retiró también
mundial pero su proyecto es un proyecto
mandato si me dan la confianza y
los islamistas retrocedan y creo que
hemos comprometido y es lo que va a
quiero hacer notar que hay 4500 los
precios si usted aumenta en 10% los
creamos hace tres años y ahora será un
después del primer paquete como la ayuda
compatriotas es cuando existe el
acompañamiento porque muchas veces
y las personas de la tercera edad son
todos ustedes por habernos seguido
inteligencia de resultados también en
quiero actuar de manera coordinada en
debe ir francia para ayudar a ucrania
razón porque eso es lo que hacen ellos y
desarrollar y de responder a estos retos
nación la política que nosotros
también porque usted vuelve a poner
ellos tienen la sensación como todos los
presidenta de la fraternidad nacional
es el fin del mercado único europeo
lo peor de la ecología punitiva y usted
revalorización para los profesores a los
pero una vez más fue necesario esperar
como
las sanciones yo estaba de acuerdo
construir nuevos cupos en las prisiones
aquellos que huyen esos países porque
hogar para hacer esto por supuesto hay
europea por supuesto es lo que he
hablando de un google europeo hay
no hicieron referéndum de su primer
la transición y
los profesores silencio y disciplina de
contra sus costumbres señor repente y en
prioridad en las contrataciones que
el gobierno les estoy dando lecciones yo
los abonos ahora es el abono se lo están
diputada le punto en contra votó en
personas de la tercera edad
independientes para nuestra energía para
hay ningún signo religioso no es
las realidades y en los barrios
constitución y le recuerdo que en
escoger a sus partidos políticos hoy de
francesa por la soberanía europea de
menos electricidad es un hecho entonces
que tener la nube donde podamos albergar
activamente un empleo había cinco
quería quería desde el principio poner
tomar ni usted ni sus representantes
potencia europea no hemos hablado de
muy bien qué pasaba y hoy comprendo que
programas de investigación y tener
en el momento en que hablamos y eso es
como fue presentado a usted también lo
el número 12 y ahora son número 26 señor
de los dos años y medio que acabamos de
confundiendo dos cosas
verdad y este referendo si soy elegida
son importantes y todo lo que tienen que
referéndum que usted quería organizar y
consumidores y además es injusta es
entonces lo que yo digo es que usted
inflación de más del 4% y para las
salvo el que tiene
mejor presidente que su adversario
el cronómetro está perfecto
petróleo que no producimos sino ayudar a
largo plazo para evitar que mañana
la ciudad
mandato de manuel marco usted esperaba a
reconocer el resultado de la anexión de
comenzaron a
hospital hay muchos temas que ustedes
construyendo un mejor mundo a través de
por ciento son las
lo hacen con nosotros pero usted no
importaba hay un
medios y creamos 10.000 puestos de
misma una pregunta siempre si ustedes
alguien si usted tomó la decisión de
minutos para convencer a los convencer a
confieso que los esfuerzos señor marco
ellos podrán tomar su jubilación a los
en este sentido lo primero vamos a
mixtas no he olvidado y pienso que el
cambiaron y están bajo control todas las
conducimos lo que hicieron los
pueblo puede cambiarla esa es la
incluyendo en alemania durante la
progresos nuestro régimen ya está
democrático mediante este referendo
en el campo más alejado todo el mundo me
precios siguen aumentando y carl y más
reelijan puede decir claramente a los
porque hay personas como nosotros
esperamos sobre todos aquí que este
edad en sus hogares yo escuché las
es muy eficaz pienso que hay que quiera
usted quiere reducir el iva sobre estos
en este archivo pero no a los
para contratar personal nuevo sobre todo
que también es el problema de la
nuestro sistema social de manera global
diferencia de muchos temas para hablar
justicia permitirá reorganizar muchas
podemos fabricar o cultivar pero a lo
hecho este personal se acusaba a sí
para las zonas rurales
solamente el velo islámico
filosóficamente considero que el sistema
somos soy europea no tengo ningún
personas que es las personas que nos
de los ancianos de la tercera edad es
sentido simplemente es así como lo bueno
abiertas
adulta pero usted decidió no hacerlo yo
las cuales son tratados nuestros otros
en mí por esta razón construye en torno
mil millones de euros en los hospitales
gendarmería nuestras a nuestros campos y
difíciles justamente todos tienen sus
hay guerra porque son combatientes de la
no es clara su proyecto cuando lo
y todas estas profesiones para
después la segunda medida es continuar
desacuerdos sinceros y respetables y
de los alumnos si quieres más prima de
sentido común de impedir perjudicar a
las cargas son trabajadores siguen
jubilación plena porque ya nadie llegará
de origen me opongo a la política que
de retiro y es un proyecto
de la energía como lo dijo el señor en
usted que hubiese hecho durante la
seré la presidenta de la paz civil esta
también hay que ser firmes y en el campo
estos problemas
manera rápida sabemos hacerlo porque
para eso hay que prohibir el uso del
eso pero estas medias se van a acumular
diferencias sobre el tema internacional
climáticos es hacer nuclear y energías
enfermedad ahora usted explica que los
algunos casos he hecho ellos mismos son
alza
señor marco
pueden invertir en todo lo demás yo
cuales les debemos tanto porque abrimos
nosotros cuatro subjetivamente
conozco sus números de salvación sobre
comenzó a instalarse o es difícil de
hecho se lo ha hecho simbólicamente al
sentimiento de impunidad cuando la
varios ejes primero en tu cuando propuse
referendo en crimea fueron las suyas y
porque se enfrentan a una competencia
áfrica continente con el cual por
en francia nacen animales que serán
defendido hable de un punto preciso que
problemas porque usted recibió al señor
quiero defender la fuerza de francia de
28 por ciento y la inflación de 4.4 por
cosas pedimos las mismas condiciones del
han obligado a las mujeres a usar el
todas las políticas que yo he defendido
menos de 300.000 aprendices y hoy hay
esto no hablo al señor marco la reforma
términos de lucha contra el terrorismo y
está tratando de llevar a millones de
desequilibrado y no está hasta mediados
no se preocupe el primero que todo
absolutamente nada
realidad entonces cómo cambiar la
con sus profesores por algunos
todas las fuerzas políticas incluso los
bajar ayudas que eran esenciales para
son reelegidos cambiarían ustedes las
manuel macro
cómo evitar que esto continúe la
ni de cualquier otro
solamente hay una manera de financiar
mandato a veces lo hicieron el segundo
la crisis y el hundimiento del hospital
estuve de acuerdo con todas las
yo quiero es que esta organización de
financiación de las jubilaciones como
hecho durante las elecciones pueden
vivir la soledad de todos esos niños y
reelecto
nuestra constitución dice que la
nos lleva al último tema que es el tema
iniciativa ciudadana y la
otros están bajo examen entonces antes
la actividad de la misma visión por
puede dividir en francia y sacar a
para los becarios creo que es muy
extranjeros yo pienso que hay que
entonces yo estoy profundamente en
también un mercado europeo que permita
pequeñas pensiones quiero llevarlas a
cuerpos intermedios de haber sido
de un precio una vez más de la energía
los últimos indecisos tienen carta
60 años después de haber pagado 40
contra
esos datos para poder controlarlos mejor
crimea recuerdo que en el derecho
el fuego y después liberar el territorio
problema es que también se había
soportar
hagan de empleados también se propondrá
intercambio nos haya ayudado a elegir en
hospitales para toda la parte material y
mccourt si usted es reelecto como
del salario mínimo porque no tienen un
una decisión que hace bajar el precio de
franceses esta noche a qué edad se
problema con eso adoro este continente
todos somos las formas de signos
entonces lo que yo quiero poder hacer es
esta tarde esta noche seguridad
libertad porque fluyen de lo peor y
están observando siempre están en un
cosas darles tiempo a los magistrados y
cuando le hacemos a esta reforma qué es
habían presentado como el mozart de las
ponemos
policías y gendarmes que están en el
profesores nos permitió continuar
relaciones miren las cosas por ejemplo
centrales térmicas las teníamos
de la justicia los franceses tienen la
oponerse a este subsidio
crisis solamente las crisis lo movilizan
velo en el espacio de majón ccoo que
de protección social de serpiente
y también en los salarios porque
porque nos dimos los medios y
de nuevo gracias a ellos nos vamos a
crisis del joven señora lepén usted
ha defendido cosas que son violentas
que decidamos hoy entrará en el 2035
mismas frases muchos de nuestros
a esa edad con el número de anualidades
campeones simplemente la diferencia que
cuando en la vida real usted va a
primero que todo se tiene la razón de
aún después de que empezó la guerra no
tenemos una agencia nacional pero hay
máximo para pasarnos en la
pero también mejor protegerlos la
soy fiel a lo que yo siempre he dicho y
estuve en desacuerdo cuando usted
cómo tenemos necesidades hoy no usted no
25.000
nuestros compatriotas
sanciones que fueron tomadas contra los
porque ningún banco francés me quiso
quiero saludar lo que hizo el gobierno
envejecen quieren poder envejecer en
la amistad que dijo que
riesgo terrorista sigue estando muy
otro lado entonces no avanzamos en este
creo que el problema mayor después de su
equivocado cuando estaba al lado de
bueno en economía y que las empresarias
supuesto tenemos que desarrollar nuevas
las pensiones la salud en el subsidio al
tomar las mejores decisiones y quiero
algo que no se acepta bien es
decisión de justicia no es lo
que ustedes han hecho para encontrar en
reemplazar la represa la bandera
nuevo 0,9 en el sentido contrario no veo
usted ha defendido de bajar de 10 a 20
importante también quiero que puedan
dice no ya no podemos más estamos
será convocado ya en el otoño para
los ciudadanos
opuso la ayuda financiera no es un hecho
putin con gran pompa en versalles lo vi
a la juventud muchísimas ayudas
que ustedes propone es pagar a los
nuestros son personas de la tercera edad
constitución y hacerla cambiar por el
salario completo porque no tienen un
reglas que regulan el uso de los signos
1100 euros para alguien que tenga una
nuestros emprendedores porque nuestro
ladrillo a ladrillo las cosas es un
exitosa toman los empleos industriales
respecto a ellos por eso hay que
va a utilizar frecuentemente los
decir de manuel bajón depende usted del
tiempo quieren hablar de la dependencia
ante estas este retorno de la
expulsarlos porque si hay que proteger a
la planificación de
velo de hecho en todos los países
cuatro mil euros a todos los profesores
república y es por eso que los
dice el consejo de orientación de
más de 710.000 y tuvimos una reforma con
trabajaremos incluso más allá de los 65
noche a la mañana sólo que ellos nos han
terreno además aumentamos los medios de
de hecho no retiró la ley o sea que
siendo pagadas en el vecino dije sí pero
millones de franceses y francesas
una casa un vehículo es el ejemplo que
usted dijo porque yo me ocupe de la
inflación pero usted siguen cantando
ucraniano y país vamos parece que
fuera del espacio público no segundo el
lo que hicieron los servicios con más de
de esta ley no podíamos ahorrar una
acompañar de sus países de origen todo
blanca su posición y comisiones suele
era difícil de incluso aceptar la
que despegar estos medios es una gran
cambiar de vehículo para salir de las
evolución de esta organización europea
después del primer confinamiento usted
es una reforma de schengen es decir
finanzas esté mostrar tiene un balance
poquito de valor en nuestro país la
es el arte del al este de escoger y yo
para las clases medias y modestas de
presidenta serán y cómo van a ejercer el
sea como sea atacar y combatirlas los
proporcional así es como vuelve la unión
desleal porque vemos con mucha
los países europeos para la unión
anualidades y progresivamente en función
que no están representadas en la
en el ftp que es un archivo aquí donde
decadencia de los
haría usted si extra directo con
entonces el costo no nos lleva a una
de las instituciones y de la gobernanza
comerciantes deberían agradecerle a
suficientemente rápida comenzamos a
geriátricos después de todo lo que fue
ciento pienso entonces que esta medida
que por supuesto aumentará también usted
jubilarán al final de un eventual
un búlgaro venga trabaja intensidad no
tema similar porque si no éste
impresión de que ahora hay un laxismo
trabajos que hicimos yo me luces de
pagar 0 por ciento de iva sobre estos
orgulloso
religiosos no están permitidas porque
soberanía le pertenece al pueblo y
presidente como va a ser usted para
aunque sean estadounidenses yo creo en
viajar y que puedan encontrar empleos
otro método de la práctica del poder es
relaciones tampoco hemos hablado de
las víctimas de los islamistas en sus
revalorizar como comenzamos a hacerlo
profesores son dependiendo de los
tiempo completo de trabajo a poder tener
conceder un préstamo en ese momento eso
transportados en camiones en condiciones
la prohibición de la regularización de
hacer esta pregunta sobre el tema
su partido lo que dije es falso señor
partir de septiembre
ciento hasta el final del mandato
lo quieren mucho pero hay 85 mil
presente y ha habido toda una serie de
alquilar un apartamento el propietario
reestructuración del sector nuclear que
gracia eso lo sienten los franceses cada
relativizando nada más los resultados no
al personal de justicia creando más de
tiene tres minutos de retraso tiene la
teníamos que explicar sobre la gente con
piensen que será de manera segura en sus
relocalización eso quiere decir que el
continuar haciéndolo porque creo que
cien
gobernanza como gobernar nuestro país
que están ahí
independientemente de los ingresos del
personales de salud se culpabilizan
restablecer su ánimo rearmar los
ciclos productivos y del modo de vida la
colectivas de la libertad de la
comprensible entonces hay que
protección de la infancia estará en el
problemas de delincuencia y de
medidas que pueden agravar la situación
tenemos que abordar otro tema que es muy
explica cómo vamos a enfrentar
estructura como esa porque a pesar que
si salvamos los empleos industrias
asamblea el que será electa en las
tomar los errores del pasado sino
esto se tiene que hacer en seis meses
referendos va a instaurar la
tiene ni cola ni cabeza porque usted
fuerza que los grandes mercados
también tendremos que recibir muchos
poder ruso y de putin
pueblo si no es a través de un referendo
trata del temor
cuatrocientos mil o sea que en materia
tenemos que también mantener el escudo y
negarse a ver que el modelo económico
nuestros compatriotas y para cerrar las
que se van a respetar no tienen derecho
muchísimas medidas para ayudarlos sobre
revolución en términos de seguridad y
duplicar las clases de primaria se nos
pensiones esa falta de productividad de
respecto al porte del velo islámico en
siquiera debían estar acá si son
en las casas seria trigás cómo hacer
realmente rodeados por la inseguridad en
europea es una estructura política que
usted tomó
de la edad a la que se entra el sistema
carrera completa en contrario a usted
crisis financiera y hoy estamos saliendo
religiosos en el espacio público por
ejerce por la vida de sus representantes
estamos formando conciencias de los
nombre de francia los medios y las vías
nuestros compatriotas todas las
reforzar nuestras protecciones del
revalorizamos los salarios para todas
inseguridad de estas brigadas tendrán un
campaña y también aquí vemos sus
total laxismo por falta de medios a
hacerlo con los delegados del procurador
musulmanes que combatieron al islamismo
hablar de europa es hablar también de
gente ya tiene miedo de que se la quiten
energías posibles como comenzamos a
cotizaciones patronales subsiguientes
30 atentados que fueron habitados el
este voto realmente muy importante
territorio y poder tener un referente de
cuando creamos un millón doscientos mil
francesa por la bandera europea en el
usted por haberles compensado las
el día en que esta guerra se termine
si creo a todos aquellos que están en
revelado y también para aliviar el
resultados de sus alumnos pero me parece
nacional cuando todo el mundo tenga la
cuatro años y usted ya estaba en el
tomado la venta nos han tomado ventaja
esto será
y comencé a revalorizar todos los demás
mandato es la desunión la división que
en contra de la unión europea
un 3 por ciento anual entonces
islamismo que no es el islam el
felicitaciones vamos a pasar ahora a un
pero vamos también a revalorizar a
nocivos para el resto de la clase a
comportamiento pero esto no debe impedir
desempleo o sea lo que permita enfrentar
defendido habría aprobado leyes y
bienes necesitamos que las personas que
años para desestabilizar
ninguna nosotros fuimos a buscar ante
palabra bueno vamos a que no va a
eso propongo 50.000 puestos de
puedo decir que se quiero que se vaya o
lo sabe si se aumenta la edad de
por ciento de la producción agrícola
nacional desde su historia
el fabricante el contratista y esto debe
dijo serán objeto de una revalorización
terminaría evitando
y del hospital son temas importantes
renovación térmica de los edificios para
desarrollar pilares industriales en el
son peores porque se liberó la para la
cónyuge creando así una dependencia más
internacional por lo que ocurre hoy el
soberanía y de la seguridad
única sanción
muy dolorosas a centenas de metros más
situación de podemos reemplazar una por
los clandestinos porque cuando se llega
extranjeros debían estar en sus casas
tiene razón nuestro país y por eso
por último está la justicia
futuros ciudadanos en los servicios
centro de los próximos cinco años su
porque nos dicen
próximas semanas no será electa de
que lo hacemos con clase el nuclear
de éxito en cuanto al desempleo
proporcional primero que nada pastori
sobre todo cuando la asamblea nacional y
escojo hacer economías en gastos que me
no poniendo
ayudarlos a hacer lo primero ayudarlos a
franceses y la que en torno a un
atentados terroristas lo siento siento
entonces en las horas que no son horas
de esos parques eólicos
siempre le pregunta cuánto gana usted
durante la crisis
nuestros departamentos de ultramar no
con ustedes y ese en el terreno de la
para que esto no se reproduzca nunca
tuviéramos un imán dijeran las peores de
pero hay un tema que es el de la
hojas de pago porque un presidente de la
coraje también y de este a oeste de
reflexionar sobre un modelo mutualista
en la dupla franco-alemán ya creo que
propios barrios porque los las pandillas
la imposibilidad de poder construir una
el espacio público
ejemplo una mujer podrá usar el velo en
millones de déficit de la balanza
posición yo siempre he sido muy claro
moralmente y también hay que amarlos y
se alcanzará un máximo de 42 anualidades
y por el referendo lo hizo el general de
euros sra
empleos estamos luchando realmente
ellos y quiero reformar el liceo
rol de estabilización de lucha contra
exterior mientra estados europeos porque
europea en un momento en que el mundo
todo en torno al valor trabajo quiero
de que rusia y chinas se conviertan en
como lo digo en su programa no existe la
que la quiere dejar en mil euros y para
las ciudades en los campos en el
solidaridad nacional
nosotros creamos en segundo lugar
desacuerdos hasta qué edad tendremos que
decisiones tomadas que consisten en
lamento que usted haya votado en contra
70 mezquitas radicales hay que cerrarlas
ucranianos ucranianas
contra la cual con la cual yo no estuve
lo necesitan aquellos que no logran
responsabilidad y esto significa
impresión de ser respetado cuando todos
trabajo para mí es algo necesario como
con esta justicia de proximidad
la amistad es un grupo franco-alemán
importante y es más bien una angustia
vale más que está dos segundos yo iba a
darse cuenta de que el personal de salud
reservas a los barrios difíciles pero
de
mejoramiento de la productividad que
permítanme dudarlo usted nos explicaba
lástima porque gracias a nuestros
mínimos sociales para hacer que el
que francia no es europa y que
preguntas hermanos en 2027 usted se
gracias a los socios debe tenerlos en
por usted depende del poder lucir usted
es dos veces más eficaz que reducir el
deben ser
habrá que levantar inmediatamente las
de mañana contiene acceso a todas las
medida de bloqueo yo no me opongo a ella
salud para nuestros compatriotas sobre
jubilación por supuesto también se va a
ataques físicos no se puede permitir que
que los demás continúen su estudio
de interrumpir se se llevó a cabo un
se mantiene el status quo cambiara la
la otra hay que hacer las dos cosas y
y después hay que poder regular a los
responder si voy a responder a todo y
estas personas de 183 euros y hasta más
enfermeros y de auxiliares porque como
y es incondicional y también quiero
veces esto hay que reconocerlo entonces
las dificultades de la vida y esto
hecho que esto no haya hablado no
islamismo yo lo combate como nadie como
propone una reducción perenne sobre los
hijo para que las parejas puedan para
feliz fin de noche para todos
perdón puedo terminar mi frase
pérdidas si usted mismo suscitó al
no se ha fijado con respecto a los
contra la pobreza señor repente esa es
comercial esto es imposible modificarlo
tema que también es una de las
y la amistad que entre francia y
país como comencé a hacer nuestros cinco
atractividad de francia sobre en ese
las cosas no puede podíamos crearlas y
bancos rusos y mucho menos bancos que
palabra porque formamos estos gendarme
aquellos que irán hasta el 20 por ciento
cinco años para cambiar esta europa y
la sobriedad 700 mil
no funciona si hay una efectividad de
número uno de los franceses desde hace
profesional y ayudar a avanzar hacia una
usted creó en medio del pueblo francés
normal porque la crisis paso por aquí y
manera proporcional porque no pudo hacer
siempre se recuperó señor de pena no es
europa de 2030 de la transformación en
los estupefacientes que tiene que seguir
todos los trabajadores hay un punto muy
ellos están muy descontentos y tienen
o se la roben o que los ataquen esto no
soledad sus dudas sus dificultades para
de la violencia en la calle de manera
veces destruyen el futuro de algunos
rápidamente también porque esto
para llegar a la paz merecen apoyo eso
que es europa para ellos porque
ilegalmente a un territorio lo único que
tener que decir lo
que me parece mucho más adaptado
responsable de una gran parte de la
las cifras los escuchamos debatir sobre
públicos también hay neutralidad pero en
entonces no trata de cambiar las cosas
yo no hago bien mi trabajo es
no estamos no somos el punto de llegada
asalariados y todas las personas que
mencioné hace un momento porque porque
ahora mucho menos hacer referendos pero
necesitamos ir mucho más rápido para no
el senado no son representativos del
establecer el patriotismo económico es
tiempo mucho menos rápida de locaciones
son extranjeros
dinero increíble entonces creo que el
bueno pues hay que controlar hay que
depende del señor putin porque después
un tema nuclear que no necesitaba hacer
porque desde el compromiso que tome es
porque el nuclear no está ahí para
significa que este tema se haya sido
parecen dispendiosos o que me parecen no
mismo
pedir que nosotros a nuestros
transporte es una situación
gaulle y de hecho si no hubiera sido
sus automóviles o pagar la calefacción
la europa de las resistencias quiere
así seré la presidenta de lo cotidiano
esto va a ser difícil pero bueno durante
bueno lamento no poder continuar sobre
revisiones de la constitución la
y también en cuanto a las jubilaciones y
llegar a fin de mes puedan recibir algo
aumentar el número de anualidades que
todo para los más viejos que hoy no
trabajar si ustedes son elegidos uno y
reorganizar de las carreras
pienso que esto podría hacer de pronto
pero a lo que me opongo es al cambio de
prioridades de los franceses ustedes ya
perdón por la referencia al mismo tiempo
años con baterías eléctricas hasta las
sistema sea más simple permitir un
nuestros precios de producción que eran
desmantelamiento de los parques eólicos
para la empresa su vida mejora pero se
importante y es lo que yo llamo el
cuando en la asamblea nacional todos los
siempre pensando en el mañana el sentido
el hospital público está amenazado con
entonces vamos a volver sobre el
sanciones contra rusia y nosotros
ley primero que todo los escucho y lo
país sea más fuerte y más independiente
eran cercanas a poder
y 62 años es muy diferente del proyecto
no hay que contentarse con una carta de
explicarle a las personas que son
cerrarlas por el tema sanitarios esta
competidores entonces se sientan en una
pero yo he leído la constitución
les permitirá proyectarse todos al
gas ruso por qué usted destruye durante
ingenieros pues nosotros
iva y me permito decir que los franceses
obtener acuerdos y avanzar como tuvimos
normal creo en la asimilación
este cambio
lo logramos hacer y un segundo pilar que
tema estamos
confiar en ellos recordarle a todos los
fundamental para la quinta república y
vecinos porque el escudo que
meses el poder adquisitivo
de acuerdo es el bloqueo de la
la calle o en el metro o será prohibido
el sentimiento de desprecio que tienen
informaciones de los servicios
alimentarios yo productos yo propongo el
cuenta en cuanto al trabajo ellos han
siendo una prioridad y ha sido
escuela o la salud va a llevar a fijar a
darles libertad en el terreno también
la francia del universalismo lo que
reforma universitaria abriendo filiales
verdaderamente preocupante y hay que dar
ningún presidente sin que yo y como
creo que es un elemento importante que
la realidad pero quisiera simplemente
las penas yo no comparto su postura
ser
que se organizan en algunos barrios a
adquisitivo sea la prioridad de mi
estamos en una economía que se está
darle a la caja de depósitos salvo los
constitución es la ley suprema del
prioridades porque vamos a necesitar
pueblo francés entonces seamos
y nacionales de las economías de los
razón lo que usted desea es en realidad
si yo no voy a hacer una política que
la ciudad
entonces lo que yo quiero es mantener
innovación por por lo digital
prácticamente un maltrato y al sistema
decir es dejar de importar la mitad de
lo que usted contempla lo que yo quiero
trabajadores franceses puedan continuar
hacerla cerrar administrativamente no
se puede hacer es pedirles a estas
decir precisamente que la mayor ventaja
demuestra que la situación es muy
nuestros compatriotas que llegan a estos
este es muchas veces a través de italia
dinero de los contribuyentes podría ser
haya que hieran a las personas que las
es que tomo todos y no tomo nada yo te
ayudamos pero que usted pueda decir que
viviendas por año
hidrocarburos pero esto es solamente un
vamos aquí
vivir en este mundo tan incierto deben
hablar por favor cierto sobre este tema
sistema de solidaridad a la fuente donde
a los autores es exactamente la
primas porque ellos saben que esta prima
controlar que hay que encontrar a los
emisión de gases de efecto invernadero
yo quiero y soy favorable a título
deben haber pagado realmente no hemos
encuentran es y eso está en mi proyecto
profesionales la alternancia el
por su economía por el trabajo por la
de unos meses de haber dicho eso usted
gratuita hay una agresión cada 40 años
partir de esta reinversión ambos ya
con soul en su lugar de vacaciones y en
política europea para ir en contra de la
turismo su instalación
permitiendo que estas escuelas tengan
alemania la ambición ecológica porque no
compromete
está en nuestra constitución y está a la
eclipsado sino que es un tema donde
francesa señora repente y las leyes que
consultores porque usted actúa al margen
culpables porque no comprando un carro
esto sobre todo crea una preferencia
la que
establecimos no es inflacionista evita
trabajan el sector que salvamos gracias
para regresar a su país de origen y a
de esta imponiendo a los franceses para
cuando funcionan además ponen a
signos o también dinero que en realidad
republicana creo que la función de la
lo esbozó un poco hace un momento es el
pero es un récord absoluto
años la capacidad de producir
sorteo y usted ganó señor me con usted
que tienen más trabajos muy difíciles
usted está proponiendo cuántos policías
otro sean honestos ambos han cambiado
la universidad y que se extranjero en
muy bajos y que fueron muy buenos para
tomamos esta elección entonces
desde hacía varios años de hecho no
consiste en esconder esto va debajo del
el primer confinamiento yo había
transportes
el tema de la agricultura que están
es muy claro la ayuda a ucrania si por
esta cobertura digital perfecta en todo
quiero reconocer el hecho que necesitan
individuales
competencias directamente en su sector
pico en los transportes quiero
calentarnos entonces con su estrategia
usted va a crear una guerra civil se lo
veces son dirigidas por islamistas y
legal ambos estaríamos discutiendo de
franceses que gracias a este personal de
ingresos y voy a apoyar el valor trabajo
razonables
ley permitió poner fin a un sistema
personas que se devuelvan a sus casas y
el cheque es algo más adaptado que la
viendo a alemania o bélgica u otros
transmisión del conocimiento debe
reforzadas del 2018 y también las
en francia el 50 por ciento de hecho o
decirle no como escuela
hundirse lo dicen todos y sobre todo
mejor utilizado
fondo público creo que hay que
la laicidad que fue adoptada pero
dicho en los últimos minutos pero la
lugares donde las personas son
conclusión de este reporte es por eso
ningún gobierno antes a través de una
bueno empezamos mark elliot en hacer
todos la impresión de que no son
del valor del trabajo del poder
industriales perdidos durante su ingenio
no se puede tocar esto para no tocar las
extremadamente graves porque rusia
tema de coherencia los segundos yo
este tesoro y yo comparte lo que usted
franceses que votaron tengan los
es llevar la edad legal que es de 62
sobre este tema un tema importante que
hundidos los hospitales no hay
pueblo y por eso es solamente el pueblo
la indexación de las pensiones este es
'quiero 700 mil por año en los próximos
la de las vacunas la de la solidaridad
común de primer ley a la lucha contra la
y eso no es suficiente lo que yo les
otros kilómetros centenas o miles para
respuestas firmes los hechos suceden en
ahorros que hace con ellos lo que yo
eléctrico aunque no tengan puestos por
eólicos que representan un
aunque sean individuales son atentados
van a cubrir o irán a correr después de
si yo quisiera salir los 10 días si digo
simplemente quiero decir que sin
a que haya menos delincuencia menos
electricidad con el renovable acabo de
las francesas tendrán un aumento de sus
no quiere explicar cómo va a financiar
de haber reformado para que esta
queda plazos de reembolso largos y eso
primero con esta infección que puede
nosotros ayudamos a los grandes que
economía digital amazon google apple
dice con mucha claridad una demostración
tomó un préstamo en 2015 ante un banco
siento orgulloso de que todos juntos
sobre las penas muy cortas porque estar
secciones son más de 1000 millones
tienes la palabra señora lópez perdón
estoy totalmente de acuerdo por
en señor repente los barrios pobres por
entendido muy bien señora tal el vídeo
tema de la seguridad de los franceses
nuestro territorio si esa persona
grecia o españa que llegan ahora también
la felicito que a pesar de un voto
como un socio nuevamente bueno primero
gracias a una fórmula directamente
de 9 bueno va a ser difícil que se
desarrollaron sus programas sus
hicimos esta transición para justamente
esos barrios siguen ahí la gente está
hablar del financiamiento de los
nivel de la nación grandes orientaciones
estar en el centro de nuestros combates
todos trabajen hasta los 65 años
a el df que hizo un trabajo formidable y
no se disculpará si hay víctimas son
inflación que le llega a las personas
claro contras porque justamente yo puse
inseguridades cotidianas la tercera de
nada porque entonces la elección
extranjera en cuanto al empleo en
les lleva una situación imposible hay
donde personas que se les pagaba por
representantes y sean minoritarios
vulnerables ésta es una obligación
entonces antes de hablar de energía
funcionar centrales de gas o de carbón
que decidí ante este reporte un programa
usted pretende establecer si es elegida
por favor son plataformas de influencia
sus opiniones sobre este tema y los
hay que hacer entonces dos cosas
el valor del trabajo es revalorizar
hacerse en un ambiente tranquilo debe
él sabe que lo que está diciendo es
europeo de la electricidad lo que nos
golpe no busquen asesinar a las personas
quiero permanecer en la unión europea
cinco años una gran fuente de economía
entonces cuando en todos estos sectores
adquisitivo de la escuela de los saberes
pedirles que vengan con una autorización
tenemos asignar más 600 mil millones de
escuela es una función de crisol
nosotros aumentamos claramente los
mostró usted mucha empatía con ellos
compartimos las cosas allí en esa
35 años lo que yo deseo es un
nuestras frutas y legumbres ya que
y por eso quiero una inversión masiva en
seguridad es como podemos vivir en
tapete porque lo que antes era corriente
escuchados de que nunca son consultados
usted no va a poder hacer hidrógeno
personal y podemos discutirlo y creo que
desarrollar la telemedicina y hay que
pesar de unos referendos no van a
arranca
usted hace para decir toma esta decisión
digo con toda sinceridad porque
aprendizaje señor marco de hecho usted
podamos o nos hayamos permitido crear 12
piensen a los artesanos a los
quienes no la firman quienes no la
facturas de algunas decenas o incluso
tenerla lo que significa poder luchar
ley que usted no votó tampoco
candidatos en esta elección que
mano del presidente y si quisiéramos
de pronto no la recibe entonces la
el que tiene derecho a modificarlas en
es una angustia para los jóvenes es el
competencia desde aliá y en europa
depende de
importar cuáles goles en los 'bous
el territorio porque si queremos hacer
proyectos porque a través de todo esto
y una balance social que es aún peor
definición pero señor depende no voy a
los particulares francés y para la
que hay que crear a nivel europeo de la
políticos y estarán ahí y de mi
garantiza usted esta noche ante los
ese momento usted dijo exactamente lo
acceso a a que van a estar abiertas al
tener mayor libertad para poder trabajar
porque porque pienso que ese no es el
considero que aquí estamos en una
sea que no se puede decir seriamente que
herramienta
cultura y creo también que podemos y
para que se puedan jubilar antes
tiene voluntad de un pueblo solidario un
eso estoy proponiendo esto todo eso es
emitir menos entonces en estos cinco
que darles más horas porque no es cierto
terroristas hay en nuestro país un
pero lo que me preocupa en su
potencias extranjeras para enseñar en
suficientes enfermeras donde ciertos
sigue siendo estadounidense estricto que
este quinquenio por primera vez desde
pero también asumir tener conferencias
muchas gracias primero que todo gracias
los alumnos y también en función de lo
sufriendo por eso yo considero que por
tiene que ser más medicalizado
permítanme recordar porque sé que los
en fin usted no tiene una visión clara
porque no se trata de decir quién está
presidencial seria ilegal desde 1962 o
antes que todo quiero sal y tratar de
materia un referéndum en pro o en contra
es la realidad
algunos sectores explicaré cómo sucede
pudiera ser independiente sobre el
pongan de acuerdo en este tema
especulación
hay muchas personas
para todas las microempresas y pymes
es un hecho señor marco no es honesto
que son empleos frágiles
de la frontera oriental que
crisis también fue terrible que
violencia criminalidad en este país si
la cual éste no hablo para nada pero que
se propondrá también la modificación del
tenemos la capacidad de poder responder
cambiar nada es la cooperación de los
para poder comenzar los alemanes es una
porque usted despidió 15 mil personas
vacunas de arn mensajero y los podemos
ayudando a los
franceses ya no entienden bien qué es lo
querer pintar la fachada pero en algún
esto se les podría ofrecer a toda
ahora ahora formamos e invertimos y
necesarios eso es evidente y lo segundo
fuimos útiles cuando nos atacaron en
también a la reestructuración que
supuesto ayuda financiera ucrania claro
pero si deseo profundamente hacer
seguridad y hay que ser más duros en
medios y la organización colectiva hay
aumentar su ofensiva y las próximas
prioritariamente en primer lugar hay que
emprendedores
falso sabe que soy una mujer totalmente
futuro del planeta los expertos de
cambios que usted quiere tendremos que
hacerse en paz y respetando al profesor
significa
telemedicina teleconsulta si queremos
una kipá o de un velo y los que
quieren firmar pueden continuar obrando
compromiso
años por cuatro meses por año es decir
y que cuando dicen algo además han sido
cambiar nuestra organización en europa
competitividad de las empresas francesas
de energía y también para la creación de
con los padres de los alumnos con los
ahí
euros y bajamos el déficit de los
hace más de 15 años podemos a
de francia justamente regional frente a
aquí tenemos opiniones similares pero
en este sistema de las de protección
la república
el globalismo la transmisión a la
este tema y si usted es elegida
por eso de la manera más clara posible
en segundo lugar hay que imponer que
de sí de 6 a 8 y sobre todo también de
repartición es decir que los activos
no señor de repente porque la edad legal
nos va a costar miles de millones y nos
en manuel marco que les dice usted a
estamos creando empleo estuve en la agua
medida que yo propongo de aumentar los
que ellos podrían hacer al lado de su
es lo contrario de los hechos lo que
vamos a combatir este problema
ruso al franken russian bank en
crear campeones significa que el mercado
no puedo dejarlo decir que una no
nosotros necesitamos una europa fuerte
bueno pero esto siempre es provisional
islamismo que en mi opinión no ha sido
millones de franceses que nos escuchan
con 5 mil millones de euros de ayudas
hay que desarrollar entonces un modelo
llevar a un delincuente dónde va a estar
demostración es el camino que toma
que se puede hacer el baño media hora lo
misma manera en que se crearon aunque se
recibieron diplomas que habían perdido
tienen que saberlo y no quiero que
mismo que yo digo en esta ocasión usted
institución tan dura por la que pasaron
médicos esto lleva muchos años ya nadie
mediante tres medidas bajar los cines
- usted anticipando esta pregunta sobre
pueblo creativo nuestro pueblo lo
permitió y lo estamos viviendo porque
establecer una situación fiscal para los
nuestro territorio podrían hacerlo en
controversia clara sus probables y su
países de origen y para eso hay que
usted no va a poder
republicano y es fundamental y esto es
mejor método pienso que eso no le hará
cientos de euros si ustedes la eligen
renacimiento democrático yo propongo un
personas que más lo necesitan creo que
el contrario esto es defender la
que propone cada uno la indepe para ser
amigos del señor vacuna han querido
estadística el rol de la asamblea
estudiantes
reindustrializar creamos más empleo de
cuando tratamos de imponer esa medida
google en nuestros mercados que nos
había propuesto 1500 euros por empresa y
de su nuevo emplear no va a comenzar
otros tuvieron por ejecutarlo para la
empresa pequeña mediana o muy pequeña
cuando en cuando un sector una empresa
muy importante todas las medias que
primeros años del mandato y comenzamos a
años tuvieron verdadera estrategia una
cuatro cosas si yo debo sacarlas aquí y
porque tendrá que refundarse después de
en este campo y pienso que usted
señores repensó por este intercambio que
nosotros logramos hacer en ese momento
es chino cómo hacer para que en el
derecho de asilo es decir que las
quiero poder tener una comisión tras
a la demanda francesa y por medio del
durante muchos años pero todo es con
esta ley en este referendo que es un
en las asambleas nacional en la asamblea
modificarla para que surja esa alianza
estos problemas si usted se tomó cuatro
negándonos a mirar a admitir que son las
francia a todos los niños de francia
hacerlo lo segundo es la lucha contra la
políticas que yo digo porque en francia
resolver el problema de la inmigración
con otros delincuentes peores es un
hablar de energía que es un elemento
de la laicismo de la república y porque
franceses sin primero me veo obligada
empleo para los constructores y ayudar a
depp en su carta blanca para concluir
integrada y para hacer avanzar europa se
debemos mejorar la vida cotidiana por
hacer todo eso que son en nuevas
después de todo que tiene es el ciber
de partido para poder actuar con quienes
validez va también perdido valor sus
persiguieron a los que no usaban el tapa
es la cifra de la productividad
que cuando usted sea presidente habrá
doméstico tiene que ser el mercado
este personal de salud
mutualista para que las familias también
cuanto a las penas y sanciones se
república defender la igualdad entre
tiene más para responder sí porque hablo
pienso que hay que ser mucho más severo
paguen por los jubilados yo no quiero un
estas son las primeras medidas con
restaurante a los industriales que nos
y reclutando y pueden seguir predicando
maltratados con palabras violentas con
porque las asociaciones hicieron un gran
sea que por supuesto que es legal y
libre y defiendo porque soy patriota a
estas redes de estas mafias que utilizan
va a tocar a personas como nosotros 4
horas los próximos días estarán marcados
siete días porque yo me reuní con ellos
los países vecinos no hemos hablado nada
el aumento del número de docentes pero
expoliación del valor del trabajo y la
siempre es transitorio nunca son medias
nacional
crear una duda respecto a esto todo
carbono y que nos permitiera crear una
que 15 mil personales auxiliares de la
ha sido comprobado en algunos casos en
quiero que se acabe con estos ajustes de
es su cambio de posición sobre la
trabajo normal yo quiero revalorizar a
permite justamente no volver sobre estos
pudimos establecer las pruebas anuales
conozco muy bien hace muchos años que he
ningún daño a rusia y sobre todo si le
lengua extranjera sin control de la
condicionar nuestra política de visas a
obtener en enero 2021 lo hicimos a
por la falta histórica de médicos y de
sobre un tema sobre el velo llevó al
momento en una copropiedad usted no
solicitudes de asilo tendrán que hacerse
hace poco la semana pasada donde en
usted quiere tomar y siento que ya no
empleos de pagos porque yo acabo de
después frenar lo asumo por supuesto no
los 100 millones podemos hablar de eso
reembolsa a nosotros reembolsamos todos
otro proyecto para establecer hay que
absurdo yo creo que hay que tener medios
proyecto que es muy transparente usted
claros usted si es presidenta a qué edad
nacional las corrientes minoritarias
pero luché en el respeto de otros para
tomar esta preferencia nacional para
médicos que los motive a instalarse en
es más eficaz o eficaz y más justo
antes de 2035 yo decidí seis
lo que destruimos mi señora depende es
cinco minutos para desarrollar pero
porque usted votó en contra de este
encuentra un médico las salidas fueron
futuro haya un google francés un sitio
respecto a hace 5 años porque 80 por
reafirmación de los principios de la
pagar la deuda estos 60 y 106 mil
renacimiento democrático con una
tecnologías no vamos a poder hacerlo si
tuvimos porque se necesitan dos para
debería irse pero esa zona constante de
1.000 euros por asalariados
anárquica y masiva porque y esto lo digo
inmediata del escudo usted ahora quiera
que trabajan los en las escuelas porque
usted acaba de decir lo segundo y se lo
duplicar las clases para reforzar esta
europea de naciones porque porque hay
eso que hay que ser coherente y
hombres y mujeres defender la laicidad
escuchan hoy vengan aquí vengan a hablar
quisiera dirigirme al pueblo pueblo
requieren que las penas sean ciertas hay
lo que hay que salvar y esto está
un garage temporal y la gente fue
hungría o en rusia no ellos sí
trabajo porque establecimos números 24/7
la guerra el referendo para mí será una
participen en la gestión de estas
van a tomar las decisiones lleva 4
inmigración clandestina
sobre todo es democrático hay que
en este debate será mejor
respecto al poder adquisitivo para
mercados no pagan impuestos que nos
nosotros pero que las demás no la van a
antes de 2035 desde comienzos pero
su salario o aumentar de 10 por ciento
vida cultura usted no está aumentando
liberalización de nuestros empleos darle
los peligros de mañana que no se
pendientes y mis medidas eran terena
si usted podrá responder a las dos
el empleador sí pero esto va a cambiar
puede decir simplemente ya no es una
los grandes temas que son el tema de la
través de un acuerdo europeo nos
reformarlo hay que reformarlos enero
por una ofensiva cada vez más masiva en
estos retornos es lo que hicimos con
deben estar allí representadas yo
importaciones las que representan el 50
y pueden seguir buscando financiación
varios partidos donde todos puedan
educación nacional le pusimos bienes del
la miseria son personas que
que no nos necesitamos cuando veo las
república y permitió hacer que lo que no
ciento era aplicable sin euro pero voy a
proyecto de ley en sí mismo que de hecho
todos los errores ideológicos de
patriotismo económico lograr que las
es una escéptica del clima
escuchamos lo que usted dijo sobre el
confianza lo que supimos hacer con la
en los consulados y envasadas de
yo no le reprocho nada simplemente lo
banco
pienso que hay que dejar de esconder el
escudo energético entonces cuando uno
analizado por la oficina internacional
de eso porque porque usted tiene una
para los niños de la república que son
digo de nuevo sus medidas como eso no
nunca puedes defender sus intereses
diplomas ya no cuentan tanto primero
supuesto le cuesta menos por eso las
mutuales y de la seguridad de una mujer
volvemos una reforma anterior pero usted
transparente en la manera de financiarlo
terrorismo para volver al islamismo y
seiscientos mil millones la gran parte
puestos quiero bajar de manera perenne
los compatriotas a cambiar de vehículo
francia estamos produciendo las palas
seguimos teniendo espacios en donde no
asamblea nacional que tenga más poder 2
proyecto que fragiliza esto yo quiero
lo que está diciendo es muy grave se lo
los meses del 20 porque estamos bajo el
preguntas margen de penn como va a ser
hay que cuestionar y también por
base para nuestra mezcla energética
hacerlo en el trabajo para competir para
2030 yo propuse una cláusula de revisión
oponerse a estos islamistas es esto
con usted para ver quien los ayudó
para los menores que permita una
personal de la salud vamos a comenzar a
los 60 darles un 3% más al año se les
rigurosa no no no es decir es el primer
lepén
no es así eso no es automático puede
que ser exigente en este tema con
por contratar el préstamo yo le pedí
velo y también un referéndum para darnos
mejor presidente que su adversario
tendrán derecho a cambiar sus cargos si
conviertan en unasur en un superpoder
poder llevar a cabo estos intercambios y
cambiar las prioridades hay que cambiar
bus francés tiene usted la palabra my
combatido con las políticas que usted ha
lo digital no tiene que existir barreras
lugares más alejados pero esto no será
referéndum se le pedirá la opinión a los
ustedes y sus préstamos
mirar su programa y ni siquiera existe
pedir el mercado europeo es un mercado
copropiedad se llama como yo he decidido
reencontrar el sentido de la democracia
salud porque usted es quería que ellos
que acabar con los ajustes de pena
energía por ejemplo que es un elemento
desapareció bajo su respuesta
estructuras en el marco que propone
ahí otra vez el tema de la reducción del
había ni una inversión desde 2012 era la
proponer algo y poder expresar su
cuando uno viene de una de un barrio
de personas que están en gran miseria
espero usted hizo algo pero si forma el
algunos países con resultados sobre
opción
podíamos hacer antes no señora no diga
sistema hídrico eso se acabó
el fruto de las reformas que yo dirigí y
productor y exportador de vacunas para
porque durante la crisis cobit no van a
porque justamente
claramente la inmigración anárquica y
francés que a pesar de la fatiga de
porque yo aunque soy diputada europea vi
también deseo y ya lo dije hacer una
para ir hasta vehículos híbridos o
que están en dificultades
están en la duración y no están
su ingenio
nuestros vecinos especialmente los
prioridad a los franceses en nuestro
eso es algo pdn lo que yo quiero y no
francia y a los franceses siempre en
por ciento de estos gases de efecto
usted no toma en cuenta los criterios de
porque incluso el bachillerato ha
cifras del banco de francia la inflación
visión que ha adelgazado en francia
violencia intrafamiliar menos violencia
pena para todas las penas de más de seis
salud en la escuela de nuestros niños y
colectividades los entes territoriales
llamó a todos los franceses a que bloom
empleador usted no puede tomar los
escuela primaria porque de hecho ya no
pienso que no hemos sido lo
vuelve sobre un sistema que ya no está
supuesto hay decisiones energéticas de
sin limitaciones pueden hacer un
europea con las que yo estoy en
mejorar las cosas para los enfermeros
tienes tiempo industrial señor depende
estructurante del futuro de un país y de
lanza que el promedio en europa me los
hay cobertura digital o por lo menos las
creo que el referéndum debe ser una
es una corrección de juicio porque la
el hospital está en crisis y lo que
la misma pregunta que se compromete a
usted concretamente para que lo que se
saben el alcalde de opinión fue hasta la
permite responder pues europa entonces
que reducir el iva y revalorizar el
porque yo me llamo señor en
los métodos hay que cambiar la manera
he sido testigo también desde hace cinco
durante la crisis del cob y quien nos
distinguen y lógico y la inmigración
en nuestro país me apoyo por supuesto en
bloquea un aumento que es de 40 60 o 100
entonces quién no quiere europa pues no
volver al bloqueo de los precios señores
para ir a los extranjeros y usted crea
mediante una ley que se dirige a ellos y
sobre todo con la implantación efectiva
algunos extranjeros que estaban
el donbass y también mariupol con los
justicia que vaya mucho más rápido
combato sus ideas y el partido que es el
invernadero por esta razón pienso que el
para boné para subir en la clasificación
cuenta de lo que tenemos que hacer
de ellas que abrirán en 2035 2023
económico monetario incluso que se
que trabaje un poco más yo os digo cómo
respecto al número de residentes en
nuclear que había sido votado en 2015 lo
pienso que las consecuencias de ese
cualquier país del mundo porque el
gracias al señor tipo montilla la señora
pobreza son los que llegan entonces
control de la comisión nacional pero
indepen bueno lo primero que hubiéramos
establecido entonces hay que poner una
más vieja que estaba en servicio y no
digo no
propio país por una razón y es que no
dijimos que había que llegar hasta el
de 2022 es de 37 y cuando veo las cifras
desacuerdo estoy en desacuerdo con la
señor marco se disminuyen después de su
nosotros para nuestra seguridad y para
el señor scholtz creo que es la buena
para los ayudantes y los auxiliares en
de la inseguridad pero bueno tenemos una
alemanes que son muy dependientes del
perdido valor entonces quiero convertir
de sus sesiones francés pierre la
su programa hay dos hechos cambiar todo
tonterías por favor no diga tonterías
continuar mejorando y llevarlas a 1100
a contratar trabajadores desplazados
ciudadanos yo sea causa no le gusta pero
de libre circulación de los trabajadores
núcleo muchos se han quejado de esto ya
ayudó con el fondo de solidaridad con el
a las cuales usted se opuso
cuestionado porque en realidad es muy
estar muy contentos aquí señora depende
sobre la escuela el valor del colegio y
del estado en la restauración colectiva
empleo sobre las ayudas a los
vean esta propuesta mía que está en el
eléctricos producidos en francia que en
la palabra desempleo ahí es un
no pero por lo menos yo quito los las
un préstamo se demora el reembolso de
masiva contribuye a la grabación de la
equilibrado entonces tiene impuestos
revisión constitucional porque en mi
poder cambiar las reglas para poder
contra la mujer menos robos menos
aprendizaje de aprendiz yo no lo que yo
el tema de la vivienda para ellos son
cinco años de confrontación permanente y
algo pero ustedes voto en contra del
denunció en estas residencias no se
como se mira la economía hay que hacer
tiene que ver con acciones de desierto
tenemos que lograr proteger mejor las
francia se ha vuelto un país continental
archivados en el respecto creemos en que
meses penas firmes cuando se trata de
no utilizan el fidel en fin y ni
todas circunstancias
opción y también tengo que decir
estos hogares y a todo precio hay que
como alemania defiende sus intereses uno
pagará además en suplemento se les
económica que necesitamos y que hay que
ley contra la ideología islamista
motoneta personas muy valientes a veces
problema que tenemos actualmente es que
prohibir el velo usted está diciendo
bloqueo nos han anunciado que sería
reforma del mercado europeo no se hace
la de otros y como europeos porque hubo
por ciento para algunas energías pues
política entre las grandes ciudades y
ha aprendices los estudiantes que
y de libre circulación de las minas no
con un francés y nadie jamás intervino
modelo económico basado en el libre
suficientemente
2050 o sea los acuerdos de parís no
completamente no señora la pena sus
puede desarrollar campeones digitales es
que solamente está dirigida a ellos que
nosotros cuatro son ineficaces porque no
final
un sistema de equivalencias en este
sensibilidad sobre los medios y medidas
tienen sino un país el sentido común de
entonces creo que el 24 de abril es un
podido hacer es que bueno como ustedes
pregunta sobre la laicidad si es verdad
islámico
ya sea una retención en un ambiente
gas ruso y por lo tanto muy dependientes
cortocircuito
suyo y su historia y su posicionamiento
conviertan en un súper puede militar lo
restrictivo y hay un halo alrededor es
usted todavía no ha pagado este préstamo
línea para el país misma pregunto señor
firmes en este tema porque el gobierno
a mí sí me gustan
multiplicación de los acuerdos de libre
había inversiones desde el 2012 entonces
este punto particular
médico donde en muchos de nuestros
escondidos o va a poner en peligro las
son las cosas
hice preguntándose lo a la energía la
del referendo de iniciativa ciudadana yo
se comprometa a comprar un vino porque
bloqueo porque
tuviera antes antes de un año de prisión
una decisión y yo la llevo y la hago en
adelante en el debate y eso nos permite
siquiera
de nuevo en
referéndum sobre la inmigración hay una
eso no sirvió para nada cerramos varias
fuertemente con nuestra policía en
los préstamos se demora y tenemos la
migración que usted tiene el peor de los
nuestra constitución esa es mi fuente la
desempleo parcial con las garantías con
fronteras lo segundo es instruir más
exigir que estas casas psiquiátricas
sitio de mi campaña allí se prevé la
internacional de los estudiantes y decir
años del sufrimiento del pueblo de sus
dramas humanos como los que hemos podido
de degradación de su nivel de vida de
discapacitados
luchar justamente contra lo que no
los próximos meses pero sé que son las
inseguridad en nuestro país esa es la
y
homicidios países garantizando yo sí
quiero también es
hay muchísimas personas que llegan acá y
en un mes señora le pen y es lo que
euros para así tener la carrera completa
representantes del pueblo usted proponen
los últimos cuatro años primero tuvimos
muy poca repercusión muchos institutos
repito que no estoy luchando contra una
claramente ser electo por el pueblo no
usted se opuso para un sistema de desde
las cosas sean claras pero las cifras
reconocimiento del trabajo bien hecho
mi reforma hacia alguien gracias a un
integridad física pero nada esto es
es un club reducir produciendo la
mejor lo mencionaba usted más bien está
las zonas rurales porque por muchas
el reembolso toma tiempo si ha tomado
este quinquenio
asumir yo tenemos estudiantes hombres
temas pero el método quiero que sea
trabajen ellos tendrán un complemento de
parte del autismo económico hay que
comercio en donde se vende a los
negociado por la unión europea después
camino que confunde todos los problemas
produzca el nuevo quisiera corregir
como vemos las dificultades que tenemos
territorios que ya sean las zonas
para llevarle alimentos esos son los
por clase con escuelas en clases más
ven tanto la unión europa como la unión
pagará la media jornada
cosas temporales sino de manera siempre
hacer que la vida sea mejor y creo que
claro
funcionan eso me golpeó un poco
lo que hace la alma de francia como lo
depende en su programa usted dice que
constatar en varias ciudades ya el rol
que todos las que realmente una razón de
el bachillerato en algo que no determine
que podría constituir un peligro muy
no quiero que aumentan los impuestos y
militar que es una de mis propuestas o
condiciones de trabajo que son muy duras
nuestra justicia establecimos los
actual no ha entendido la gravedad de lo
el técnico
entonces terminamos con unas cifras que
funcionaba en su programa cuando yo
para mejorar las instituciones lo
aumentar los ingresos de estos
elección por una energía descargo nada
un bloqueo europeo nos enviaron al
momento claro y creo que la elección
independientes dijeron que serían 13
para los próximos de los cinco años que
por uno pero nunca había los dirigentes
pensiones de los jubilados verdad señor
balances de los últimos señores años
para usted pero es un país mundial y
político pero la respeto como persona y
fue también revalorizada en noventa
privación incluso de las libertades
se transmiten en los precios sino que
comisión de cuentas de campaña que es
dispositivo de carrera larga tiene un
números están equivocados y los números
tan cierto esto que en realidad las
firme
porque no es europa el que decide
razón por la cual voy a proponerle a los
primero que todo uno de los puntos que
posible tengo muchas otras cosas para
el respeto de los demás si hago avanzar
inquietudes he visto como el palo se ha
lo que usted está proponiendo
la toma de sus propias cotizaciones es
piden del asilo ya está en la calle si
la prohibición con respecto a las
10 mil kilómetros para consumir 10.000
expulsión de los criminales y
nosotros lanzamos hay una diferencia
rápidamente y llevamos a cabo una
no respetar la constitución francesa
si usted aumentará o no al número de
profesores ya comenzó en este quinquenio
falso primero que todo encontré un tweet
dimensiones del día de la economía la
vio hay bío extranjeros no solamente vio
en el parque instalado con las
que estoy dando son ciertas ciertas y
nuestra francia
es lo que yo no quiero porque mi
yo les preguntaré si quieren desmantelar
construimos una solidaridad y pudimos
mujeres que vienen a trabajar y que
hacer relocalización de las actividades
constitución francesa la república laica
cotización diciendo yo escojo mis reglas
y que nos mantiene al tema del velo es
deseo que 500.000 franceses puedan o
claro porque de otra manera no me podría
cuando digo esto soy creíble porque yo
entonces tenemos nos tenemos que
religión ni contra el islam que es una
aumentó pero yo sólo he visto franceses
brazaletes
la el impuesto sobre las ventas sobre la
segundo es que creo que los competidores
refugiados mujeres niños ancianos
pequeñas
son problemáticos entonces lo primero es
trato de comprender lo que está detrás
geopolíticas pero discúlpeme yo termino
de acuerdo con la política con respecto
luego con el conocimiento
trabajos de interés general bajo control
hacen todos los países del mundo señor
tiempo somos un partido pobre pero eso
como yo
europea se mete en todo incluso lo que
muchos estímulos financieros que se les
asociaciones que no respetaban la ley de
grave para occidente para europa y para
entre usted y yo lo que usted declaró es
franceses defender los intereses de
usted cambio completamente de opinión
tiene que ser clara los 40 segundos que
internacional y terminamos convenciendo
además son injustas y ustedes no
propuesta de revisión constitucional hay
porque es el que permite la
empleos que se están creando y yo creo
decir que las cifras en regular que no
rurales o algunos barrios y en este tema
de francia y el rol de europa es como
se les rechaza se quedan en el
lo paga este estudio son los
inversiones que yo decidí desde el
hacerlo
francia debe volver a encontrar esta
franceses un referéndum de estos
hay que ir mucho más allá por supuesto y
profesores bueno voy a responder pero
quiero poner las matemáticas hasta el
es exactamente lo que está proponiendo
productividad quisiera hablar de la
invertir en este sistema de salud para
delincuentes extranjeros
pienso entonces que este bloqueo tendría
será más fuerte si se logra tomar la
quiero convencer a todos aquellos que la
euros por año o algo así ni siquiera me
muy severa y rigurosa y saben todo esto
cifras de desempleo si a los
preocupado por un desplazamiento por una
democrática
dieron su
de lynce están ahí y es un organismo
de su reforma del trabajo usted
que es el islamismo radical pero usted
primera reforma del organismo a cabo de
da derecho con de reconstitución sin
euros por mes y yo soy favorable a poder
los bajé en este mandato de 50 mil
aprendices y los que alternan trabajos
decir sobre este tema pero nada de eso
o los demás los siguen porque no aquí
ayudan hasta este país a ser más fuerte
religión y tiene todo el derecho de
hay que re industrializar nuestro país
presentar para ser presidente de la
no solamente ecológico hay en el
es una traición al espíritu francés yo
individuales y las libertades colectivas
mantener este escudo tan tanto como sea
objetivo mi prioridad mi obsesión es
naciones que se cambiaría
bajo nuestra identidad nuestra tradición
a la energía nuclear una gran diferencia
estos estos informes de la onu
clarificación sobre nuestros proyectos y
coordinador hay que imprimir que haya
contesto un año el marco y marín de penn
google no se creó por un gobierno se
no la concierne y a veces impone
son cifras de las de srt cuando se dice
energía de 20 a 5.5 por ciento porque
nuestros socios no nos conformamos
contribuyentes pero como en la reducción
estamos hablando de religión es una no
son los míos que son los de los
producto usted miente sobre su producto
porque quiero cambiar usted voto en
que usted quiere salir del mercado
indivisible social el gobierno del
el pleno empleo no yo soy muy claro
empezó su mandato eso es cerrando nunca
den a los médicos no serás digno si no
principio del quinquenio la rentabilidad
a los estadounidenses estadounidenses y
para estos pequeños delincuentes y no
el gobierno y me siento orgulloso es el
emisiones
su futuro totalmente
territorio porque solamente hay 10% de
poder levantar al hospital y poder
la república las unas porque tomaban
no nos de sandro yo creo que ha
distancia la patria de las luces del
también dura la supresión del derecho de
que me han hablado de sus problemas con
ucranianos y ponerlos en el lugar seguro
primero quiero decirles que la juventud
varias cosas que están en la
ambición de grandeza de influencia en el
extra sido presupuestados y ya su
respetarla porque la constitución es el
el tema de una religión de un signo
es decir cambiarla sin pasar por la
seguramente hablaremos más adelante para
baterías eléctricas y queremos
pero yo yo he sido abogada y los
república
y ellos dicen que su programa no es
desempleados a veces eran de 5 millones
inteligencia del mañana los niños de la
y está regulada con cartas de residencia
prácticamente quiere eliminarlo y usted
supuesto que el sistema de carrera larga
es posible si no se construyen nuevas
para quienes tienen tienen carlos viejos
incluso desde francia los intereses de
me quedan quiero y hablar de los niños
a pesar de esto aspira a la tranquilidad
arriesgaría con esas cifras cuando
consecuencias cataclísmicas no solamente
francia esos son los límites que yo
organismos independientes de lince y
también
independiente pero esto permitió
no va con no ha contestado la pregunta
hay que ayudar a las microempresas y a
extranjero que tienen normas menos
se tomaron las decisiones de 2018 yo
una enfermera las 24 horas y también hay
considerado que se ha deshonroso pero es
bien someter a la votación de los
esta instrucción reducimos la crisis de
nosotros lo hicimos desde el principio
con respecto a las eólicas en su
consideró que con el poder adquisitivo
también medidas para aislar y alejar a
está matando al planeta mi proyecto está
directivas que son contrarias a los
existir lucho es contra la ideología
somos 27 en esta mesa o usted hace una
siguieron hablamos de muchos temas y
en efecto corregir este efecto que usted
nacional y local nuestros valores
justamente que los franceses puedan
presidente que creó 600.000 millones de
esto le vales mucho a los franceses
bachillerato en de la reforma que
creó por emprendedores que tuvo
constitución y pasaré por el artículo 11
de cada vez yo hago ahorros por otra
para poner este impuesto mínimo de 15
el último sector en el cual intervendré
especie de precariedad generalizada
progresivamente a la unión europea yo
sobre las cifras
bajamos en libia para los en las
millones a 25 mil en los impuestos sobre
las ejecuciones de las obligaciones de
no tiene sentido no no no tiene sentido
volver a contratar y hay que mejorar las
su segundo lugar deseo que vuelvan los
otros establecen que el poder
pueden ir con sus familias si no hay
desarrollar eso y también acompañar la
pueblo por el pueblo y para el pueblo
poder decidir en algunos días hemos
usted está hablando de religión de
mundo incluso con socios y aliados
precisas que envío francés no compraron
religioso exterior el tema del velo
asamblea nacional es simplemente lo digo
primero que todo mandó apoyar a ucrania
que hay 570 mezquitas radicales hay 570
cuestión ecológica que ustedes buscaban
pero nosotros duplicamos el ritmo de
sobre los signos religiosos
justamente la sharia la falta de
con el fin de cambiar radicalmente la
marco mismo de la elección porque creo
en pepiño polonia ha recibido cerca de 3
delincuentes piensan que esa es la
sostenible eso es lo que dicen los
creo que
el poder adquisitivo sólo franceses que
nuestros intereses vitales y a nuestra
simplificar las cosas usted lo va a
bajé yo puse fin a la baja de la falta
programas para ayudar como nosotros que
aspira a que regrese el sentido común en
universal sería el primer país del mundo
los productores y de los agricultores y
formación de la educación de la juventud
apoyó una ucrania libre que no esté
porque somos y estamos interconectados
islamista que está afecto que está
franceses la derogación de una ley o
nuestro idioma nuestros paisajes y
ellos no pueden con esos carros no
hicimos ir también poniendo en la media
la seguridad es uno de los elementos
lo planteo yo solamente empezaré las
el cronómetro están casi en el mismo
también hay temas vitales para nuestros
significa que quiere salir de la unión
permitidas yo se tienen que haya que los
euros de deudas suplementarios nada que
crea riqueza y así con esto tampoco se
la conversión presencia de 65 años
y medio cuando usted fue elegido y son 5
eso es lo que yo quiero hacer el
las de pie a las pymes dándoles
programa la señora lepén quiere
estas personas violentas y eso para mí
una parte apreciable de estas de estos
trabajar en su propio país por eso es
de deuda que tomamos juntos para
al suelo porque creo que la nacionalidad
quitas de irse el territorio porque todo
yo estoy por a favor de la interdicción
describió muy bien y que cuando una
contaminan los paisajes es intermitente
también he visto como el suelo se ha
todo el mundo sabe qué es lo que no
por ciento para los grupos que hacen
transición industrial como la tranquila
transporte para ir a la ciudad vecina si
impunidad total cuando se pueden hacer
hay una segunda cosa sobre lo que usted
ya lo dije claramente
y convertirse en una gran potencia
desarrollamos a sus programas pero se
condiciones de trabajo para poder tras
me han dicho que ya no alcanzaban a
europea o que la unión europea como es
ideología que utilizan la religión en
para que resista apoyar ayudando a los
privilegiados especialmente los países
tiempo de palabra sobre el poder
mantener correcto si o no estoy
política de inmigración para que al fin
porque tiene usted la palabra acabo de
miles de francesas y que trabajan en
seguridad e incluso a nuestros intereses
es el de las personas vulnerables porque
diferencia con usted la segunda es que
reconocerá conmigo es que esto crea una
igualdad entre las de hombres y mujeres
productos ecológicos franceses que los
atravesado como usted lo acaba de
reducción de gases de efecto invernadero
en función de su edad segundo lugar
en prohibir los signos religiosos en el
compatriotas que no pudimos evocar es la
puede financiar nada ni en nuestro
proteger lo que hace que hoy señor de
es una prioridad la segunda es la
tiene 15 ó
desmantelar las no queremos true ir más
necesita un mercado que funcione que
como lo hizo el general de gaulle en el
ganaderos y los industriales franceses
ajustes en las penas si la pena es
hora cotidiana de deporte que es
hacerlo sin complejos
hay momentos donde importamos la energía
la gestión de los asuntos de estado el
pueden ir a las grandes ciudades aunque
renacimiento democrático que le ofrezco
las empresas pienso entonces que no se
sometida ni a los eeuu ni a la unión
sobre los combustibles y el gas
preocupado por el futuro incierto
llevarlos a trabajar de nuevo y mantener
esto hay que consultarlo porque la
atacando nuestra república la igualdad
mezquitas radicales su ley no ha servido
persona tiene esa ayuda que se casa con
hogares geriátricos que no las tienen y
someter al pueblo francés un proyecto de
estudiantes lleguen al comienzo de la
millones punto 4 ahora nadie con todas
francesa se hereda unos hereda no se
esenciales y es una solicitud
dijo está el combate contra el islamismo
una banda aparte de su programa y
simplemente los franceses decidan quién
quieren la unión europea y qué es lo que
que yo lucho el valor trabajo encontrar
adquisitivo pasemos al tema interno otro
transición agrícola para poder reducir
obras es súper aldo que fla móvil se ha
recordar señora un periodo muy difícil
cómo está hoy le conviene con la dupla
votos porque tomaban nacionalismo
dependencia
no pueden llevar a sus hijos entonces
penn cuando vivimos una pandemia como lo
francia en su ideología
francesas que trabajan y que son en la
precisó y
pienso que durante su ingenio han sido
francófonos de áfrica que son socios
descuentos de impuestos y no como usted
sistema de protección social ni los
usted está más bien a favor sobre todo
y lanzamos una política para la
del uso del velo en el espacio público
se basan en gas y en carbón y esa no es
necesiten ir al hospital por ejemplo
inmigración es un problema que gasta
económicos eso por un lado pero por otro
eso es lo que yo quiero hacer lo que
no tengo más dependencia que la de
permita avanzar lo segundo es que hay
también propone una alianza con rusia y
quiero que los estudiantes que trabajan
a los franceses tiene algunos segundos
30 segundos cuando digo europa piensa
este proyecto se es viable incluso es
no hay que confundir las dos cosas
puede obtener automáticamente también se
62 y como lo defendió después en después
importante para aprender mejor y es un
podamos tener en todos los comedores de
regla del juego' el tema de que
sentido común por ejemplo de ayudar a
llevar un brazalete o ir a reportarse a
quiero cambiar y lo haré con aliados
espacio público el primer país del mundo
para nada ustedes estableció una carta
europea rusia esta es mi posición es la
las inversiones y una serie de medidas
capítulo extremadamente importante en
puede venir quién se puede quedar y
hombre entre hombres y mujeres que ataca
está de certificación continuará y esto
las emisiones no por inducción sino por
ya lo he dicho claramente pienso que el
educación secundaria dominando
perfectamente legítima de los franceses
que no producimos aquí y como estamos
también fortalecer europa es lo que
extrajeron nuestro territorio otros
ley con estos referentes lo dijeron los
biodiversidad quiero ir dos veces muy
una persona que tiene más dinero lo
puede uno hacer el harakiri eran dudas
tenemos millones de compatriotas cuya
históricos con quienes definitivamente
sean ayudados quiero que ellos tengan un
que proteger a los ciudadanos a europa
desarrollos necesarios pienso que hay
con crisis sin precedentes una pandemia
muchas energías de nuestra sociedad en
muy maltratadas en estas personas
trabajo crear trabajo y restituir el
nuestros compatriotas más vulnerables a
clase media y populares han aumentado
vimos desde hace un siglo a pesar de
eso es lo que usted está proponiendo no
vital que soy yo es el proyecto acaso el
lado él jugó el europeo hace años que en
reembolso con un banco lambda en el
que yo propongo y acabar con las zonas
las eólicas en el mar sí bueno primero
deseo es que la comisión europea respete
franco-alemana como motor primero
estas circunstancias el tema
modelo mutualista de los hogar
solamente tenemos el tema de la igualdad
la mejor solución solución no tenemos
delante y
hemos hecho en los últimos años y es
hablará de la prioridad nacional para la
quién se debe ir para que hagamos
la democracia que ataca la laicidad
interconectados necesitamos el mercado
pierde es cierto que el gobierno no
de hecho la situación del país es
que se confundió como yo lo señalaba
porque eran de extrema derecha y qué
del 62 dice que el soberano es el cuerpo
rápido en el próximo quinquenio y lo
también creó los primeros estándares
perfectamente el idioma lo que no es el
punto fundamental para el aprendizaje
la comisaría eso es lo mismo que nada yo
velo es un uniforme impuesto por los
es una injusticia nuestros compatriotas
muchos campos tiene un luto largo para
que hacer un esfuerzo considerable sobre
chalecos amarillos ellos miraban a la
pero las cifras en promedio no vienen a
complemento salario porque los que
nuestro país y hay algo de lo que no se
hay que volver a crear una versión es
tiene ninguno no es el respeto de
habla de bajar siempre es para los
europeo simplemente hay y como lo hizo
todo después si pudimos reducir el
los discapacidad 2 el 25 por ciento de
importante este momento creo que estas
como no habíamos desde hace más de un
para nuestros datos individuales en el
[Música]